and yet another old disney film finds
itself in the chopping block this time
it's snow white in the seven dwarfs
the path to cancellation begins with the
recent reopening of disneyland i don't
have to reiterate my general view of
theme parks especially ones owned and
operated by disney i'll only say that if
disney world is hell on earth which it
is
i could only imagine what disneyland
must be like disneyland is the knockoff
version of hell it somehow manages to be
a downgrade from hell it's like going
from a comfort into a motel 6
or from a mcdonald's to a burger king
but that's not the point here the point
is that the website
sf gate owned by the san francisco san
francisco chronicle
published a review of the new disneyland
experience
it was mostly positive but it did
include this bit about the snow white
ride
it said quote the new grand finale of
snow white's enchanted wish
is the moment when the prince finds snow
white asleep under the evil queen's
spell and gives her true love's kiss
to release her from the enchantment a
kiss he gives to her without her consent
while she's asleep
which cannot possibly be true love if
only one person knows it's happening
haven't we already agreed that consent
in early disney movies is a major issue
that teaching kids that kissing when it
hasn't been established if both parties
are willing to engage is not okay
it's hard to understand why the
disneyland of 2021 would choose to add a
scene with
such old-fashioned ideas of what a man
is allowed to do to a woman
especially when the company's current
emphasis on removing problematic scenes
from rides like jungle cruise and splash
mountain
why not reimagine an ending in keeping
with the spirit of the movie
and snow white's place in the disney
canon but that avoids this problem
yes and what a problem it is lots of
bigoted right-wingers have been making
fun of this passage in the article but i
don't see what's so funny they raised a
good point snow white
was actually not only sleeping but it
was believed that she was dead right
it's been a while since i've seen the
movie but she was she was dead i mean
they thought she was dead
the dwarves put her in a coffin until
the prince shows up and begins to
sexually assault a woman that he
believes to be dead this is
normalization of necrophilia
as well as rape culture and what about
those dwarfs
we're just going to leave aside the fact
that they attempted no form of
resuscitation
no first aid of any kind before deciding
to put her in a coffin and leave her for
dead
well i mean wasn't she if she was just
sleeping she was breathing
they even tried splashing some cold
water in her face or something
put her in a in a glass coffin that was
exactly the right size
i might add did they just have that
lying around
they invite a woman into the house and
they have a coffin her size
waiting outside for her these troubling
questions go unanswered
that's all to say nothing of the fact
that none of the dwarves to my knowledge
were voiced by actual doors
just as a magic mirror was not voiced by
an actual magic mirror or even a regular
mirror
representation matters and snow white
gets it wrong on that front time and
time again
and what about snow white herself now
not to victim blame
but she's in her kitchen one day when a
random creepy old hag
shows up at the window giggling
maniacally
and pushing a piece of fruit into her
face and telling her to take a bite
and she does can you imagine someone
knocking on your door
and they got an evil smirk and they say
hey i got an apple for you
why don't you take a bite and you say
well gee i am kind of hungry
chomp what kind of food safety message
does that send to our kids
suffice it to say there's plenty of
reasons to cancel snow white and not
just her let's get it all over with why
trickle the cancellations out let's do
them all at once
why hasn't aladdin been canceled yet
yeah they remade it and injected some
you know additional wokeness into the
screenplay
but the whole premise of the movie is
one that normalizes and romanticizes
forced labor
the genie is a slave in bondage
imprisoned in a tiny cell
and has to sing and dance and perform
tricks in order to win his freedom
it's no wonder there are so many white
supremacists in this country when
they've grown up on
movies that normalize the enslavement of
people of color
specifically the color blue in this case
but still
also the lion king it celebrates
autocracy through the problematic
benevolent dictator trope embodied by
mufasa
meanwhile the marginalized hyenas are
cast out into the dark lands
and when scar the marxist revolutionary
leads the hyenas in a class uprising
it's cast by the film as a nightmarish
event
the audience is meant to cheer when the
privileged son simba returns from his
sabbatical to claim the throne
kills the revolutionaries throws them
into a fire
the whole thing is highly offensive and
problematic
what about pinocchio the film ruthlessly
reinforces the gender binary
by by revolving around pinocchio's
desire to be
a quote real boy now a simple change
here would have turned it from a
bigoted hate fest into a true artistic
triumph
pinocchio would have needed only to
transition into rather than a real boy
a girl or a trisexual polygamist
or even just simply a pansexual lesbian
non-binary
semi-female genderqueer starbucks
barista
yeah why not that but there's no
salvaging it now pinocchio should be
canceled
beauty and the beast needs to face
consequences the one good thing about
that movie is that it has a very
progressive attitude towards sex
belle enters into a romantic and
consensual
for the most part i mean she was
imprisoned by the guy so
yeah but aside from that a romantic and
consensual bestiality relationship with
the beast and that's you know very
progressive very enlightened
uh surely [ __ ] that should be applauded
but the rest of it is profoundly
objectionable
consider the teapot character a woman is
made into a literal object
it is the most blatant case of
objectification ever put to film
and that's nothing compared to the to
the other character the feather duster
if you can believe it the movie depicts
not only a woman turned into an object
but the object is an actual feather
duster
now any old misogynist will say that
women should do the cleaning but it
takes misogyny on steroids
to suggest that women should actually be
the cleaning
my god cancel beauty and the beast
cancel them all you know we need to move
past movies as a society
if you want to be entertained just stare
at a blank tv screen that's what i do
create your own movies in your head last
night i sat for three hours and i stared
at my screen and i imagined that i was
watching
an action film about a black disabled
lesbian trans woman
beating up oil executives and nra
lobbyists
hollywood thinks it's woke but it isn't
work enough to make that movie yet
maybe it never will be and so for now
disney is cancelled all disney movies
are canceled
all other movies are cancelled it's all
canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated